una versión que genera controversia la
organización forense de Irán desmintió
este viernes a la familia de maxam Mini
esta entidad niega que la joven de 22
años haya muerto el pasado 16 de
septiembre entre eran como consecuencia
de Los Fuertes golpes que recibió
mientras se encontraba bajo custodia
policial después de haber sido detenida
presuntamente porque su hijaf no cubría
al completo su cabeza este informe de
forense replicado por los medios
estatales recoge que la muerte de maxa
aminí no fue causada por Golpes en la
cabeza y en los órganos vitales y en
extremidades la organización forense
Explica el deceso en una cirugía de un
tumor cerebral a la edad de 8 años en un
principio la policía explicó que la
joven había sufrido un ataque al corazón
aunque su familia argumentó Kia mini no
sufría de complicaciones cardíacas el
gobierno anunció la apertura de una
investigación por este caso mientras el
país ha vivido tres semanas de
manifestaciones que se han convertido en
las mayores movilizaciones en los
últimos tres años organizaciones en
defensa de los Derechos Humanos
que más de 150 personas han muerto en
estas marchas a nivel internacional la
muerte de Minnie también ha generado una
oleada de protestas
desde Nueva York la activista iraní
explica que este malestar en las calles
podría ser un punto de giro
está ocurriendo una Revolución para mí y
para millones de iraníes y está siendo
liderada por mujeres y apoyada por
hombres y es un momento crítico para la
República islámica
Mientras tanto las muestras de rechazo
contra la actuación de las autoridades
frente a las marchas continúan
apareciendo en Irán este viernes un
artista anónimo tiño de rojo el agua de
algunas fuentes de Teherán en
representación de la sangre derramada